did you watch the
did you uh I don't know we don't have to
get into AI I I was just I always saw
some clips let's get in speaking of
Clips I saw some clips of
Sam Altman on Lex Friedman
oh didn't see that what was he saying
he just scares the [__] out of me
it's like I feel like just deep down
this guy just doesn't care about the
human race
who is he he's the founder of open AI
okay okay oh yeah the the non-profit for
the future of the world yeah exactly
yeah the non-profit that became for
profit and now is worth 30 billion
dollars
he was like talking about like how to
say like solve world hunger we should
change our government's you know
structure we got to think about how we
get everyone on the same place
economically right yeah yeah exactly
yeah I mean he no but it like people
think AI are gonna do those things sort
of but also there's the risk that it's
gonna just kill everyone you know and
he's like yeah there's he's like I would
be
I I definitely empathize with people
that are scared and that's all he says
it's like no tell us it's not gonna
[__] happen please oh he knows dude
he knows look at these eyes you know
what's crazy is that okay so Chad gbt
for example is one
large language model right yep and
that's trained
and that's you know smart
up to the knowledge that it's been
trained on you know right and then I'm
pretty sure the more you use it right
the more it also learns
about right humans speech patterns and
just about what they search for and all
that stuff right right well now they
just released
the ability
to it's like essentially an app store
hmm for chat gbt where you can build
apps on top of chat gbt you know just
like you can build an app that lives on
top of the iPhone operating system you
can do the same thing now with chat EBT
so now chat EBT can use the internet
because that's an app
you know there's like an Open Table app
or whatever where like like learns your
restaurant preferences and everything
and you can just basically there it is
right there you can like I've never used
it actually but I'm assuming you just
now it's like a chat GPT interface for
Open Table where you're just like hey I
want a reservation for four and it knows
your preferences and all that stuff
which is genius but then everything now
now like karna shopping for example yeah
and Shopify and all this stuff so now
it's getting data and Expedia now it's
getting travel data it's getting
shopping data from everyone in the world
who's using these apps and it's learning
all of that too
did you see that eventually this will be
the smartest thing
in the universe
yeah
because they don't know everything about
everyone and every every single tendency
and habit a human has yeah it'll know
no 100 see what you're saying I actually
had a similar and Sam Altman is in
charge of it so he's going to be emperor
of the world is what I'm saying I think
he knows that I think that's why I think
he does too I think in the back of his
mind he's like I'm gonna be [__]
emperor of the world
yeah
I actually had a similar conversation in
that um
I know this is going to seem obvious and
everything I'm about to say is very
obvious but
uh I was I was just kind of spinning out
on the diffusion process of mid-journey
the thing that was like really freaking
me out about
mid-journey is like mid journey is just
essentially the beginnings of like a
mathematical like imagination it's just
crazy like you can now use this to
essentially give software
imagination if that makes sense people
minimize it I think when they say things
like oh AI when people use AI
and when they kind of make fun of
mid-journey like oh it just puts
pictures together it's it's it's so much
scarier than that did you see that thing
with wolf from Alpha the app no no so
wow I I forgot about that website right
all the time
so there's this thread on Twitter you
should look it up
someone used chat GPT or no no someone
yeah someone was kind of prompting chat
GPT and chat PPT was able to solve a
problem that wolf from alpha hadn't been
able to solve
or like it was something where
I said something about this yeah yeah
like created an answer and kind of like
nonsense but it was nonsense that could
be understood and it was sort of whoa
the app store is
is gonna be like one of the biggest
things on Earth yeah well I mean that is
the most it's just the most impactful
technology release
in the past 20 years by far yeah and it
was so low they're so low-key about it
they're just like oh this is kind of an
experiment
yeah here's an App Store where anyone
can now build on top of
like the smartest language model that is
out I mean bro how much easier is it
gonna be to open up
instacart chat GPT and you just go hey I
I need someone to pick up and you just
copy and paste everything well I think I
know another another like Insight I
think is that uis are going to stop
being a thing like a screen yeah touch
buttons of pictures of food because as a
human you just want to say it yeah you
know what I mean it's like if you had
something that was constantly like you
know in Iron Man or whatever like yeah
you know it's just a just something that
was constantly listening where you're
like uh yo order me some ribs from blah
blah right now that's gonna be a thing
in the next six months you know well bro
it's gonna be so funny because it makes
me wonder how this impacts advertisers
and stuff because
uh and it makes me wonder how certain
apps feel about I guess they don't
really need to track your finger presses
anymore if they know everything you're
buying and everything you're searching
and it's almost easier to just comb a
user's like raw text input but would be
so funny if
uh like the internet started with just
like raw text on like plain HTML pages
and imagine our operating systems just
like go back and all our phones are are
just like it's a prompt window and you
just tell it what you want yeah and it's
like it's there's yeah there's no uis
anymore like there's no yeah none of
that like it's just like a [__] ask
Jeeves text input box and you're like
yeah yeah your phone is like just Angry
Birds
[Laughter]
Angry Birds and the prompt did you see
that ruling not ruling but
I'm trying to figure out how to phrase
this basically there's a ruling where
you can't copyright
uh images from mid-journey
okay you can't like copyright anything
that's like driven by AI okay guess I
guess copyright law now like in terms of
like visual stuff you have to be able to
prove there was like human touch I think
is the phrase okay which I thought was
pretty interesting yeah like to kind of
like protect artists and stuff that is
really interesting I mean this like kind
of feels like DRM like way back in the
day when Napster was around it's like
yeah you can try as much and it kind of
ended up working which is weird but it's
like during that time it was like yeah
you can try as much as you want but it's
like
teenagers are going to [__] download
music on Napster and they're going to
figure out how to steal and share with
each other people are kind of talking
about how this this change in the law
right here
kind of protects people that make like
stock images and stock footage
because imagine if like
imagine a few years when this gets so
good like you'd never need to like
anyone that creates stock photos or like
stock videos like it's just it's gone
like you don't need it anymore which is
yes
that's just one like everything yeah
yeah customer service not gonna be a
thing anymore yeah that's an entire
industry completely wiped out in the
next like two years yeah but it's like
everything I don't even know what's
going to be left
okay
I know that's like weirdly like alarmist
and sensationalist but
when I think about this I'm like I don't
know what the [__] the world's gonna be
like in two years three years
I so I think in that regard with you
know
I mean you know maybe this this is the
[__] that like cannibalizes capitalism
and like that's the end you know yeah
very well could be
maybe maybe it's a good thing but like
that that being said though like
you know even though we've had the
internet and everything for the past
like whatever 30 years yeah
um like there's still people on like AOL
they're still like old people using like
the oldest version of
You've Got Mail and [__] like that you
know
yeah
I think there's the like Legacy systems
stick around for like a lot longer yeah
but if you wipe out everyone doing I
mean I guess in a way like customer
service jobs
you know like call center jobs that's
going to affect
people overseas because you know every
job has been [__] outsourced from
America
for the most part like they outs like
companies here try to Outsource as much
as possible so
it's you know it's that thing that we
were talking about where the only people
without jobs are going to be everyone in
Silicon Valley and all the programmers
yeah
there's just gonna be every software
company is just gonna it's just gonna go
back down to the Five Guys that always
knew computer science and they're gonna
be like the ultimate prompters and the
rest of everyone who is like faking it
and copying and pasting stack Overflow
answers those will be the ones that get
canned I think it's just the only person
left is gonna be Sam
the the emperor of the world